Thank you guys so much.
This is really awesome
to be on the stage today.
Over the past year,
I've spent a lot
of time talking
about web components,
really teaching developers
the basics of the standards
and teaching folks how to
focus on building elements.
And we're now at
this place where
we have this burgeoning
ecosystem of elements
that are out there.
There's a lot of developers
out in the open source world
who are creating
elements but also got
element sets that have been
created by the Polymer team.
We've got the core and
the paper elements.
And so we're at
this point where we
have this flourishing
ecosystem and I
think it's time for
us to start to think
about the next challenge, which
is how do we leverage that
ecosystem to actually
build real applications.
And I'm particularly
interested in figuring out
how to build compelling
experiences on mobile.
The mobile web has a
ton of opportunity,
but it's one of those areas
where for web developers,
it's always been a
challenge to create
a real compelling experience
on a mobile device.
And so when I was preparing for
this talk, what I wanted to do
was just like pop my phone out
and look at the applications
that I use all
the time, things I
consider sort of
successful experiences.
And I wanted to go through them
and just sort of catalog what
I see as the kind of common
UI and UX expectations
in a successful app.
So what I've got
here is Twitter,
I've got Pocket Cast for
listening to podcasts,
and I've got RDO.
And one thing that struck
me as I was doing this
is if I just take
these applications
and I put them side by side,
even though each of them
kind of feels unique when I'm
looking at it in isolation,
when they're all
lined up like that,
it feels like they're just
like a ton of commonalities
in their interfaces.
And so using Twitter
as an example here,
I want to just catalog some
of those common UI patterns
that I see.
So up at the top,
we have a toolbar.
Pretty familiar.
And oftentimes, if
you've got a toolbar,
you're going to fill it
up with some icon buttons.
And below that,
you've got some tabs
for switching between content.
You've got a primary
content area,
and oftentimes,
you're going to have
like an infinite list of
contents inside of there,
or you might just be
lazy loading more content
as the user is
scrolling down the page.
And down at the bottom,
you've got a secondary toolbar
for doing additional
actions of some kind.
Now, if we take
a step back again
and we line these apps
up again, like when
I was looking at
Twitter a moment ago,
it felt like a very
unique experience.
It felt kind of
aligned with its brand
and it had kind of its
own thing going on.
But again, I line
these guys up and I
can see that they all
kind of have those same UI
patterns going on.
They're all kind of doing
the exact same thing.
And the reason they
all look the same
is because they're all
built using an SDK.
So these are examples
coming from Android,
but the same is true if
you're working in iOS.
If you're building on
one of those platforms,
you already have this SDK
that's available to you,
grab a bunch of
components out of it.
Maybe you kind of tweak
them a little bit,
color them differently.
But in general,
you're using stuff
that's already available to
compose your application.
Now, on the web, we've kind of
never really had this thing.
We've never had app
building primitives.
We've never had
a mobile web SDK,
and I think it's time
for that to change.
And I really think
that the way that we're
going about doing this is using
Polymer and Web Components.
So my goal today is to teach
you how to build mobile web
applications using
these new technologies.
And I basically split
this up into four parts.
[? The very ?] part, I'm
going to show you just
how you can structure the
UI for your application,
then we're going to look at
how you can transition from one
state of your
application to the next.
After that, we're
going to look at ways
to make sure your application
is performant, because that's
really crucial for a
mobile application.
And lastly, we're
going to look at ways
you can make sure your
application runs offline
because if your mobile
app doesn't run offline,
then you really don't
have a mobile app.
People are oftentimes
on their mobile devices
when they're in low connectivity
to no connectivity situations.
So it's got to
run offline for it
to be a real, compelling
mobile app experience.
Let's start with structure
and just think about ways
that we can compose the
UI for our application.
And really, that's the
key word here-- compose.
What I want to do is I'm going
to take as many preexisting
elements from the Polymer
core sets to the paper sets
and I want to bolt them together
to build my application.
So this is the app
that we're going
to be working from today, just
a really simple contacts app
that I threw together.
And I'm trying to utilize
a lot of the same patterns
that I was showing in the
previous successful apps
that I had before.
So you've got the toolbar at
the top with some icon buttons.
You start scrolling
around, you're
going to get this sort of
infinite list of content
inside of there.
You've got a drawer panel that
you can pop out for your menu.
Clicking on any
one of the contacts
is going to do kind of
like an animated transition
to show you that
person's contact details.
I get it's really nice, cool
condensing header effect
as I scroll around.
And also, I've got a little
floating action button
down there in the corner.
I can click that, pop
open another screen.
These are all
animated transitions
that I'm using here.
Now, if you've seen
me talk before,
you've probably seen me start
off by using this element.
Anytime I'm building
an application,
it seems like I'm
always starting off
with this core
toolbar element, which
is just a really
simple container.
It lays out its
children using Flexbox
and it's a really
good place to get
started with one
of your screens.
And because
composition is really
the name of the game,
what I want to do first
is I want to just throw
some additional elements
inside of here, and I
just want to compose
the UI for my toolbar.
So I've dropped a paper
icon button inside of there.
I've configured it
with an icon attribute
to give me the hamburger
menu from that application,
and so I'm going to
slide out my menu later.
I've also dropped a
div inside of here
for the title of my application.
Now, one of the cool things
about the core toolbar
is that since it uses
Flexbox, I can kind of
take advantage of
that a little bit.
There's things called layout
attributes in Polymer,
and what I can do
is I can actually
tell the title of
my toolbar that I
want it to flex to take
up as much space is
it can inside of the toolbar.
This is a really
handy trick to know
because it means that
I can then pin controls
to the other side of my toolbar.
What I want to do
here is actually
add a little context
menu so I can
have things like
settings and feedback.
So to do that, I'm going to
use another element called
paper-menu-button, and
paper-menu-button's
pretty interesting because
by itself, it really
doesn't do anything.
It's kind of useless.
If you just put a
paper-menu-button tag
on the page, you
get really nothing.
It only really
comes into its own
when you start composing
other elements inside of it.
That's really how you
unlock the potential of it.
So I've got another
paper icon button
that I've thrown inside
of here, and that's
going to give the user
something to click on.
Then I'm going to throw
in a paper drop down,
and that's going to give me
this little animated rectangle
thing up there.
So when the menu
expands, it's going
to kind of like come
out from the corner,
expand towards the
center of the site.
The halign attribute
that I've thrown
on there is going to
indicate which direction it
should animate from.
So here, we're
telling it to animate
from the right edge towards
the center of the screen.
Lastly, I'm going to throw
a core menu inside of here,
and that's going to give me the
actual menu items that users
are going to select for
my sending them feedback.
Now, the cool thing
here is that each
of those elements that I threw
inside of my paper menu button
is useful on its own.
I can use core menu elsewhere
my site if I need a menu.
What's awesome,
though, is when I
start to compose
these things together,
I get different interesting
complex behaviors.
And it's also
important to point out
that I didn't write any CSS or
JavaScript to make this happen.
I just nipped together
these-- oh, yay.
Thank you, [? Demetri ?].
These elements just know
how to work together
because they're app building
primitives, which is awesome.
And once I'm happy with
the look of my toolbar,
then you take all of this markup
and I could throw it inside
of another element
called core-header-panel.
And the core-header-panel is
just a really simple container.
It's got a header section
up at the top, which
will hold the toolbar,
content area down below.
And the cool thing about
the core header panel
is it only really cares about
managing the scroll behavior
from my application.
If I put a toolbar
inside of it, it's
going to make sure
that that toolbar stays
sticky up there at the
top of the document
and all my other content is just
going to move underneath it.
Again, no CSS or JavaScript
to make this happen.
These are just
smarter primitives.
They know how to work
together like that.
Now, when someone's actually
looking at one of my contacts,
I want to have this cool, big
shot of Addy Osmani's face
basically, and I want it to
do this cool animating effect.
So as the person
is scrolling down,
it kind of collapses,
and it's sort
of crossfading with
the background image.
And to do that, I'm using a
cousin of the core-header-panel
called the
core-scroll-header-panel.
It's basically the
same component,
but it adds this nice
condenses attribute,
and it gives me that
kind of cool effect.
Now, once I have the different
screens for my mobile site laid
out in a way that I like
them, I can drop all of this
into another element
called core-drawer-panel,
and that's going to
give me a responsive
scaffold for desktop and mobile.
And the way this
element works, it's
basically got a drawer area.
Any content that I
place inside of there
is going to end
up in my sidebar.
It's got a main area.
Any content that I
place inside of there
ends up in the
primary content area.
And the cool thing
is, this element
is responsive by default.
So if I'm on my desktop and
I just start dragging it out,
you'll see the drawer
panel opens there.
I can open and close it.
I drag this thing out, and
when I hit a certain size,
the toolbar just
pops out for me.
This is really nice.
Again, I'm not writing any
breakpoints or media queries
to make this happen.
The element's just responsive by
default, which is really nice.
Now, at this point, I've built
the skeleton of an application.
I've kind of shown you
how to put the shell
around everything, but
what we're still missing
is the lifeblood
of our application.
We're missing the content.
And when I'm showing
these apps earlier,
I mentioned that oftentimes
what they're going to do
is they're going to do
like an infinite list,
or of a lazy load of
content so the user can
keep scrolling through
all of their tweets,
or all of their albums,
and things like that,
and we can achieve the same
thing in our application using
an element called core-list.
And core-list is one
of my favorite elements
because I feel like it's
sort of the thing that
knits all the scaffolding
and the content
together in this way
that I really love.
The core-list is basically
a virtualized infinite list.
You connect it to
a data provider
and then it stamps
out a template
for every single instance in
that data provider's array.
So here, I'm saying
list.data equals some array.
I've got objects
inside of that array.
Each of those
objects has a name.
And inside my core-list,
I have a template element
and I'm just binding to
each of those instances
as they come in.
It gives me this really,
really performant infinite list
so I can go through
all of my contacts.
Now, as I was building
my application,
I kind of came
across this thing--
which I'm going to
share with you as a tip
if you want to go out and
start using core-list yourself.
One of things that
core-list does
is it recycles its children.
That's actually how
it's so performant.
It makes a fixed set of
children and as they're moving,
it's pulling them back
around the other way.
So if you have image tags
inside of your core-list,
you can end up in a situation
where you're basically
racing the network and you're
having stale images fly
past the screen, and
then they catch up
and change, which
sort of looks weird.
So I found that there's an
element called core-image
which you can use to
prevent stale images
in your application.
It's pretty easy.
You just drop it in here.
You give it a preload
attribute, and what
that does is it says, hey,
if I'm loading an image,
I'm not going to display
the stale image that
perhaps was inside
of here before.
I'm just going to display
a little background color.
And so what we can do
now is we can actually
have this cool contacts list.
We can sort of
race the networking
and you can see the
images loading in,
but what you're not seeing is
stale images, which is good.
The other thing that I
discovered as I was doing this
is that it's really important to
make sure to set your core-list
scroll target to your
core-header-panel-scroller.
I know that this is a
little bit of a rough edge,
but I wanted to make
you guys aware of it
if you're going to go out and
start hacking on these things
today.
Basically what
happens when you do
this is you're
telling the core-list
to listen to the scroll events
that the core header panel is
firing and that way, the two
can work together in harmony.
Now, there's two ways that
you can go about doing this.
You can either set the
scroll target in JavaScript.
You could say list.scrollTarget
equals hPanel.scroller,
or you can do this with bindings
if you want to be really fancy
and impress your friends.
You could just say scrollTarget
equals hPanel.scroller.
Now, this is one of those
things which, again,
I think it's a little
bit of a rough edge.
Perhaps we might be able to
clean this up in the future
so that you don't have
to wire this up yourself,
but I wanted to
make you aware of it
because it was like the
first thing I wanted to do
was put one of those
lists inside of one
of those fancy
headers, and I needed
to set up this linkage
to make it all work.
Now, through the beauty of
composition, I've taken my list
and I've thrown it
inside of my scaffold,
and I have this really,
really cool application now.
Now, I want to give
you a quick recap
of what we have inside of here.
So up at the top, I've
got a core toolbar.
After that, a paper-icon-button,
a paper-menu-button
for my contacts menu.
I've got a
core-header-panel, which
is controlling the scroll
behavior for my home page.
I've got a
core-drawer-panel, which
gives me that
responsive scaffolding
so it works on
desktop and mobile,
and I've got a core list for
my infinite content provider.
Now, one thing
that's really cool
to do once your application
has reached the state where you
feel like it's kind of
shaped up a little bit
is to think about ways
that you could change it.
And if I look at this
and I just imagine
perhaps applying a little
CSS to that toolbar
and perhaps adding a little
bit more content to the list,
then I'm really not
that far from something
that looks a lot
like Inbox, right.
All the parts remain
the exact same,
we're just tweaking slightly the
appearance of them-- changing
some colors, adding a
little bit more content--
but we've now got a very
different experience.
And because the core list
supports variable height
content-- meaning that
our rows don't all
have to be the exact
same fixed size--
we can think about throwing
cards inside of here.
And if we do that, then we have
an experience that looks kind
of like G+.
And again, none of my
markup actually changed.
I still have a core-toolbar, I
still have paper-icon-button,
still have paper-menu-button,
header-panel, core-panel,
and core-list.
So my markup remained
the exact same.
The only thing that
changed was the content
that I'm placing inside of
it, which is pretty cool.
Now in my mind, this is
the power of composition.
When we have a mobile SDK
that's full of these really
good generic building blocks,
we can build vastly different
experiences just by arranging
them differently and tweaking
them slightly.
I think that's huge.
So let's go back to our
contacts app for a second.
We've got the basic pages
kind of figured out,
but I haven't really shown
you how to move from one state
to the next, and this is a
dilemma for a lot of folks.
They start building components,
they get really excited,
they throw them
together on a page,
and then they're like,
how do I go from point A
to point B. Basically,
how do I do transitions?
And this is one of those
areas where we're still
working on it, but
I think we've got
some really cool
stuff in the pipeline.
One of the elements that I've
shown before which I think
is really awesome-- I put this
little experimental badge on it
because it also is a
little experimental--
but it's so freaking
cool I like to show it.
It's this element called
core-animated-pages,
which gives you a pluggable
system for transitioning
of one state of your
application to the next.
And basically, the
way this works is I
put some sections inside
of my core animated pages.
I configure its
selected attribute
to tell it which section should
be displaying at the time,
and I give it a transitions
property and I tell it--
or sorry, transitions
attribute to tell it
which transitions
I would like it
to play as it moves from
one state to the next.
And with basically
just that I've wired up
this is really cool
system for animating
through different states
in my application.
So inside of my app, my markup
kind of looks like this.
I've got a whole bunch of markup
that makes up every single page
and it's all kind of
composed together.
And so the way that
I'm going to transition
from one state to the next is
actually take all this markup
and turn each section of my
application into a custom tag.
Keep all that markup,
make an element out of it.
Then I start nesting
those elements
inside of core-animated-pages.
So I start with
my contacts page.
I drop in an info page for
when you click on a contact
and you actually can
see their profile.
So I created a little
custom transition here
called fade scale.
It's on my info page
as an attribute.
It's also in the
transitions attribute
for core-animated-pages.
So now when you click
on a contact, which
is going to animate up,
so you're adding there
and then it goes away.
And again, for the page
where I add a user,
it's basically the same thing.
I nest that element
inside of here.
I give it a transition.
I add that transition to
animated-pages transitions
attribute.
I click on my floating
action button now, pops up.
I can add a new user if
I want and it goes away.
Now, another tip that I
want to share with you
is something that I came
across as I was building this.
Core animated pages
does this thing
where if an element
is not displaying,
it's going to make it display
none, which can totally
screw it up if it's trying
to figure out its height
or do anything like that.
So this magical event here
called core animated pages
transition prepare,
which is the longest
this event name in the
history of the world.
But this event
does magical things
because it basically fires the
moment that your element goes
from being display none
to being display block.
And that means that you
can then do all the work
that you need to do to make
sure that things are measured
and have the right height
and everything like that.
Again, this is one of the things
that I'm sure if you see this,
you're like dude, that
feels like a wart,
and I totally agree.
I think you're right.
And this is one of
the things that I
know the team is
aware of and we're
going to work on to see if we
can actually smooth this out
for people so you don't have to
do all that finagling yourself.
But again, I wanted to
make you aware of it
so if you're following along
with this video or something
afterwards, you want to try and
implement this stuff yourself,
you know how to do it.
So at this point, I have all the
sections of my site together.
They animate, they
do really cool stuff,
but really that's
just animation.
We're not really changing
the state, per se.
We're missing the other half of
the puzzle, which is routing,
and this comes up a lot.
Developers are always like,
how do I do routing in Polymer?
And Polymer and Webfluenz don't
really have an opinion here.
We're not going to
tell you specifically
you have to do routing this way.
There's really two ways
that you can go about this.
You can do it
imperatively in JavaScript
or you can do it
declaratively with element.
And so I'm going to show
you both approaches,
and you can decide
which you prefer.
So if you're going
the imperative route,
looks something like this.
It's really as simple
as just listening
for a route change using
some sort of routing library.
Here, I'm using flat
iron director library,
so when I hear a route match, I
tell core-animated-pages, hey,
change whichever page
is currently selected.
It's pretty straightforward.
Now, one of the nice things
about routing in JavaScript
is it gives you pretty fine
grained control if you want it.
So if there's
parameters in my route,
I can catch those when
the route matches.
I can go fetch more
data if I need to
and feed that to the
page, or I can just
pass those parameters
to the page itself,
be like, here you go, here's
the parameter that's coming in,
and change.
So some interesting stuff there.
One thing that is pretty cool,
which I wasn't actually using
my contacts as I
experimented with it.
I think it's a really cool idea.
It's something
that we're probably
going to be using a
lot more in the future
is this notion of
lazy loading imports.
So actually, let's say
you've got part of your site
that's four or five
pages deep, someone
doesn't need all of those
components right away.
There's this
mechanism in Polymer
called Polymer
Import which you can
use to just sort of
dynamically import things.
So you can add that
to your router.
You can say, hey, when
that route matches,
that far away route, let's
import some of that new stuff,
maybe throw a loading
screen up during that time.
And when it's ready, Polymer
Import gives us a call back
and we can change that page.
So that's the JavaScript
way of doing it.
There are also projects out
there which do this in markup
with elements.
In particular, there's
this really cool one
called app-router
by Erik Ringsmuth.
It allows you to
handle URL changes
and update the views
in your application.
It handles hashchange URLs,
as well as HTMLs history API.
So you get either
flavor that you prefer.
The other cool thing is that
it actually already supports
core-animated pages and
doing lazy importing
with Polymer import.
But it does all that
under the hood for you
so you don't have
to do it yourself.
So again, two options.
It really depends
on which flavor
you prefer, but definitely
try both out and see
what you like in
your application.
So this one, I feel like I have
my application pretty sewn up.
It does all sorts of really
interesting behaviors.
I'm pretty stoked
with the way it looks,
and now it's time to
focus on performance.
Sorry, that's the wrong
slide-- performance.
There we go.
I love that lady's face.
One of the areas that people
run afoul with Polymer
often is the route file size.
You'll even hear this.
People will be like,
Polymer's too big.
It's just bloated, whatever.
And there's some ways that
you can mitigate this.
First is this thing that I
stole from Glen Maddern, who
is the creator of x-gif, which
is the most important custom
element ever made.
Yeah.
Thank you.
If you haven't seen x-gif
you should take some time
and spend it with x-gif.
So one really quick
win that you can get
is just conditionally
loading the polyfills.
You don't have to load the
polyfills on every platform.
There are platforms
that support them.
Chrome supports it, Opera
supports it, Chrome for Android
supports it, and hopefully
very soon Firefox.
So all we're doing
here's is just
checking to see if the different
standards are implemented
on the page.
If they are, we just
move right along.
If they're not, then
we load the polyfills.
So this is an easy
way to save yourself
quite a bit of kilobytes.
Just conditionally load stuff.
That's one trick.
And the other thing
you've got to do
is you've got to actually
pop open the dev tools
and you got to make sure that
you're inspecting your page.
So I looked at the
contacts app after I
built it and was
very proud of it.
I popped open the
network panel there
and I saw that I was making
109 requests-- which is a lot--
and I'm loading 943
kilobytes of stuff.
Now, keep in mind, I
have excluded the images
from this network panel,
so that's just my code.
Holy crap, that's a lot.
I recognize that 109
requests for some of you
might be concerning.
But what's going on
there is under the hood,
I'm importing elements.
Those elements
have dependencies.
They're importing
their dependencies,
and so on and so on.
It's basically this
whole tree that's
growing out of my application.
And so to mitigate
this, we created
a tool called Vulcanize.
And Vulcanize is a module
which will actually
take all of your imports,
concatenate them together,
smoosh them all together,
take all your JavaScript
and your CSS, mash
it all into one file,
and allow you to
just load that one
thing into your application.
Now, it is available
as a node module,
but if you are not so stoked
about doing everything
on the command line, it's
also available in a Grunt
task and a Gulp task.
And for the contacts app,
I just used the Grunt task.
I set it up once and I just
never thought about it again.
It just runs every
time I'm about to push
to production, which is cool.
Now, after I
Vulcanize and I make
sure to put my stuff on a server
that supports [INAUDIBLE],
my application is
now three requests,
which is a significant change.
And I've got it down
to 114 kilobytes, which
is pretty nice.
Now, this is all the code
for my entire application.
This is all the
JavaScript, all the CSS,
all the HTML for my
entire application.
So I've got it down to
114 K, and this number
gets actually even
smaller, much smaller,
in Polymer 0.8, which is cool.
Now, the last thing
we've got to do,
we've got our app to
the point where we're
ready to put it up there,
share it with the world,
but we've got to make sure
we're thinking about offline.
Because again, if your
app doesn't work offline,
you really don't have
a mobile experience.
And I know that we've talked
a lot about ServiceWorker
today, so I will talk about
it again here because it's so
freaking awesome and
I'm so excited about it.
What I did was I added service
worker to this application.
Pretty straightforward.
I just checked to see
if ServiceWorker exists.
If it does, I install it.
Important thing to note
here is that as I'm
installing my
ServiceWorker, I've
got to make sure that I'm using
the root scope so that I can
catch any request at sort of
the top level of my application.
If you nest your ServiceWorker
inside of a subdirectory
or something like
that, then it's
only going to have access to
the request in that scope, which
sort of sucks.
You want to put it
high up if you can.
Inside my application,
as soon as we boot up,
I just try and cache
as much stuff as I can.
You'll notice that I'm caching
the vulcanized bundle of all
of my elements.
So my UI is just like
instantly available.
I'm also caching the initial
response from my data service
so that there are contacts
to populate my list there.
And then the other
thing that I did
was as the user is
scrolling around,
I'm dynamically caching
any sort of image
that has a host
name from S3.amazon.
So as you pass through
an avatar image
and call this S3
response method.
And really, all it's doing
is it's fetching that image,
it's caching it, and then
serving up for people.
So as user kind of
uses my app, it just
consumes things for them.
Now, if we pop
this open in Canary
and we've got Service
Worker running,
we started running our app.
And what I'm doing
here is at first,
I'm just racing to the
bottom of my application.
And right now, there's no
Service Worker in play,
and so what it's doing
is loading all 300
of my contact images at once
and just hammering the crap out
of the network.
And you'll see
it's like, oh God,
why are you doing this to me.
And it finally all
starts to load in.
Now let's refresh
it and see what
happens when
ServiceWorker's in play.
Let's turn our Wi-Fi
off, refresh the page.
You'll see here
over in the column
that our assets are now
coming from ServiceWorker.
So I race to the bottom
of my application.
All those things are just
coming in immediately.
There's no wait on those
assets, which is really cool.
[APPLAUSE]
So, wrap up.
What did we learn?
For structuring
your application,
for structuring your UI, you've
got the core and the paper
elements.
So you can compose
those together
to make a really awesome
mobile experience.
From moving from one state of
your application to the next,
you've got core-animated-pages,
and you've also
got imperative or
declarative routing.
Kind of depends on how
you like to do that.
For performance,
conditional polyfills.
And most importantly,
vulcanize all the things.
Use Vulcanize to bundle up
as much as you possibly can.
It'll save you a lot.
Also, consider
exploring lazy loading.
It's one of those
things that we're still
trying to figure out what's
the right pattern, what's
the right UX there.
But it's something
that I think we'll
be seeing a lot
more in the future,
especially in the
world of Polymer.
Lastly, for offline,
ServiceWorker's got your back.
So as that starts to land
in the various browsers--
I mean, even today,
experiment with it.
As it starts to land in various
browsers, put it in your app.
It's going to be really awesome.
If you want to play around
with this contacts app,
it's available up
on the GitHubs.
It totally has a lot
of bugs, so please
file bug reports, but even
better, submit pull requests.
If you want to learn
more about Polymer
and you're just
excited by everything
you've seen this afternoon,
as Matt mentioned,
we're running Polymer
events all over the world.
We call these Polytechnics.
I see some of you
wearing the shirts, which
means you are cool.
If you go to
itshackademic.com, you
can find a Polytechnic near you.
If you want to
participate in one,
maybe you want to run
your own, whatever,
all the material is up there.
If you set one up,
please let me know.
Tweet about it, whatever.
It's freaking awesome, so you
should all go check it out.
Most importantly,
polymer-project.org.
As you've all been sitting
here, we've actually secretly
been updating the website.
So there's kind of a
new experience there.
It's just a slight-- it's
just a nicer coat of paint.
It's not a full blown
reboot of the site,
but now it's a lot easier
to find the content
that you're looking for.
The getting started experience
is a lot easier if you just
want to get up and
running with Polymer,
so definitely
check out the site,
go through some
of the tutorials.
And I'm looking forward to
seeing all the really cool
stuff that you guys
build, so thanks.
[APPLAUSE]